الاصلاح معا جمعهم حمله
اعادت الحياه لعشرات البيوت التي دمرتها
اله الحرب في اوكرانيا شباب وشابات قادم
من داخل البلاد ومن دول اوروبا للمساعده
في ترميم ما تبقى اليوم جاء الدور على بيت
ناديه سيده خسرت كل شيء بسبب القصف الروسي
لم نرى المنزل يحترق لاننا لجانا الى
الطابق السفلي لمده يومين وبسبب القصف
المتكرر لم نخرج بعد ان حاولنا الخروج قتل
زوجي والان نحاول ان نبني منزلا جديدا حتى
يتمكن حفيدي من القدوم لزياره وحتى لا
ابقى وحيدا معاناه ناديه وغيرها اثرت في
اوين الذي جاء من ايرلندا حتى يعطي من
خبرته في ورشات البناء لهؤلاء الشباب
العمل ليس سهلا وفي هذا الحرب على الرغم
من اننا نعيش في خيم الا ان الوضع ممتع
نحن نبني منازل للاشخاص الذين يحتاجون
اليها حقا نرى يوميا هؤلاء الاشخاص ونشاهد
معاناتهم ولا يمكننا التوقف عن التفكير
فيهم علينا بناء المزيد من المنازل
في نهايه هذا الاسبوع جاء اكثر من 150
متطوعا الى قريه لوكاشيفكا للمساعده من
بينهم كاتيا اوكرانيه تعيش في باريس لكنها
قررت ترك كل شيء للمشاركه في الاطلاق
قد كنت هنا منذ اكثر من ثلاثه اسابيع
ويسعدني حقا ان اكون قادره على اعاده بناء
منطقه والمشاركه في شيء اكبر بكثير من
مجرد التفكير في نفسي كما تتيح لنا هذه
الخطوه ترك انطباع جيد مع مرور الوقت
بعد يوم طويل من العمل يحين وقت السهر
والاستمتاع هذه المره بحفله موسيقيه قد
تونسيهم ولو قليلا ويلات الحرب وتعب
المهمه